hi I am Elizabeth Rubin journalist
former colleague of David Rhodes at the
New York Times and I'm here with David
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist many
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist and
authored the new book indeed the FBI the
CIA and the truth about America's deep
state hi David how you doing I'm great
and thank you Elizabeth for doing this
and being such a great colleague over so
many years and a friend sorry I should
just disclose that but she's gonna be
tough on me she said so here we go where
are you exactly
I'm up in Maine we left New York just as
a pandemic started my wife has reduce
lung capacity and we're up here staying
with family and it's very lucky we've
got a very easy up here that's great I'm
glad to hear that well you're really
wonderful and I'm probably not the first
person to ask you this can you tell us
what is the deep state I'll kind of bury
or help I'll ruin the whole interview by
saying I conclude that the term eight is
sort of political rhetoric that Donald
Trump uses to marginalize experts you
know members of the intelligence
community
Tony foutch II in terms of a public
health expert and just to dismiss them I
do think there is a permanent government
I am you know that both liberals and
conservatives fear liberals talk more
about they use the I think a better term
is the military-industrial complex right
ours talk of defense contractors and
generals who push us into endless wars
and then conservatives talk about the
administrative state and that's sort of
an ever-growing federal bureaucracy
that's invading our lives and taking
away our rights and freedoms but deep
state I don't like the term it's very
effective the president's a great
communicator yeah but it's where does it
come from
so it's an old it's been around for
decades Turkey was where I first found
it was Hughes political scientists have
talked about in terms of
Turkish military kind of warding the
emergence of democracy there some people
have talked about it in Egypt for
earlier we were the poster behind
Elizabeth shoulder is an attention movie
poster I've done very little reporting
there Elizabeth - done far more but it
was also there was a talk of a deep
state in Egypt again a powerful sort of
military and intelligence Nexus that
would thwart the emergence of democracy
in Egypt but it it was used for decades
in both of those countries but it's only
really recently it's been used in the
u.s. there's nothing to do with deep
throat like it didn't have that kind of
no no and one of the characters in the
book can we talk about this later a deep
throat is actually a senior FBI official
this is all public Mark felt he was
involved in in terrible FBI abuses in
the sixties and seventies and actually
put on trial for that and he never
revealed that he was deep throat the
source for Woodward and Bernstein and
Watergate but no it's a it I don't know
how where it emerged in Turkey or Egypt
and it but it was first brought to the
US by that I found a professor at UC
Berkeley I can talk about more about
that US history if you want but yes yes
why not tell us you know his his the
first reference I found was its name is
Peter Dale Scott I tracked him down he's
now retired he comes it comes at it from
sort of the liberal perspective he sees
the deep state more in terms of the
military-industrial complex but also
Wall Street and sort of big corporate
and financial interests and I think and
I'm gonna get this wrong but I he wants
it more like an economic corporate deep
state correct that there is and again
the the and it's it's so to back up and
you're right to interrupt me you know
there is a problem the American public
on the left and the right thinks that
there are unelected powers whether it's
wealthy bankers or big defense
contractors or CIA and FBI officials
that are secretly running the country
and there is an element of that and you
know
talk about it and that's very dangerous
elected politicians including President
Trump the elected president United
States you know should have power the
bureaucrats should carry out the
president's orders if they're if they're
legal mm-hmm and and that's a basic
thing of democracy so that's one thing
that the Trump is right about but
there's this deep deep suspicion that
goes beyond Trump on the right and the
left and I think you know mainstream
journalists like us it would be kidding
ourselves if we don't recognize how
alienated people are from the government
from the media and these kind of things
so Peter Dale Scott it's a post 9/11
suspicion there were conspiracy theories
that you know the CIA and the Mossad
together had staged 9/11 that was
widespread you know from your own
reporting you know in the Middle East
but even Americans believed it so I
think it was 2003 or 2007 I should know
this but Peter Dale Scott wrote a book
called the road to 9/11 and it blamed it
was the first place I found where the
term deep state was applied to the US
government and he blamed the deep state
for dragging the US and two wars over
and over again and particularly for for
facilitating or engineering 9/11 so that
the US military could then you know
invade Afghanistan and Iraq and so he it
was a critique it more along a line to
interrupt you did he believe that the
u.s. intentionally facilitated 9/11 no I
think that he he his thesis would be
that the military and intelligence sort
of complex took advantage of the 9/11
attacks then carry out invasions and
boost its budgets and it's and get more
power surveil Americans and do whatever
they wanted and then what's interesting
here is that he comes out with this book
after 2001 and he ends up there's
interest in him on the right so Alex
Jones the far right conspiracy theorist
right with his awards program has Peter
Dale Scott on as a guest and you know
Peter Dale Scott talks about the deep
state this is all in the mid 2000s and
it was interesting talking to
recently the Durham sort of takes off
and it starts circulating on the right
it's still on the fringes but as the
term has become so pronounced sort of
post Trump selection Scott feels like
the term has been sort of misused it's
been it's been cheapened and and that
it's it's so it's applied so broadly now
that it's it's gone beyond the
definition he wanted to use he still
thinks there are powerful corporate and
wall street and defense industry
interests that have all this influence
in Washington and that's where he thinks
the focus is true it is true and I and
this is the challenge of the Trump era
and trying to write this book that these
are this huge economic bias in our
policies the CIA and the FBI and the NSA
or more powerful for than ever and
Edward Snowden showed that but Donald
Trump's allegation that there's a coup
being plotted against him the the claim
that Tony Fauci is sort of some
conspiracy to undermine President Trump
that is false like that's an
exaggeration and exaggeration that's you
know Trump makes for political gain but
we need to figure out how to control
these agencies and we need to how to you
know the government and maybe
journalists need to figure out how do
you make Americans trust their own
government more so in in your well
actually before I ask you that what what
just why did you decide to write this
like what did something happen did you
what inspired this I I had two things a
a former CIA official who I had met
overseas but had retired
it was during 2016 it was a period when
people didn't really expect Trump to win
but he complained to me that technology
the internet and you know texting and
everything we have now was leading to
all this micromanagement of CIA station
Chiefs in the field by CIA leaders in
Washington and politicians in Washington
and so he claimed that that instead of
the CIA being rogue and doing things
that
you know not authorized the problem was
that politicians were sort of
politicizing intelligence that they
would limit any intelligence they would
produce in the field different would
hype it if it helped that politicians
agenda or they bury it if it didn't
agree with that politicians agenda so he
said you should be looking at you know
we're we're obeying the system and we
can talk about the system that emerges
in the 70s and are they really obeying
or not but he said that we're doing the
right thing the intelligence officers in
the field it's the politicians that are
you know abusing the system and that
that sort of surprised me and then the
last thing there was a poll that came
out and I think early 2017 that showed
that 70 percent of Americans believed
that they were on elected officials in
Washington who were secretly influencing
government policy 16 or 17 20 17 and I
started and liked it it became most
people didn't know what the term deep
state actually meant but when you said
do you believe there's a group of
unelected officials in Washington who
secretly influence government policy 7
and 10 Americans said yes I think six in
10 thought they were being improperly
surveilled and just the last thing about
that poll the two groups were the
highest fear of the government were on
the right NRA members and then on the
left and this makes sense in a week
obviously if George Floyd's killing but
racial minorities again that's very
broad lack of trust in government
something particular happened with this
CIA agent where he or she was
particularly personally affected so it
was it's Richard Lee who's a character
in the book and he talked about feeling
that you know his his father was in the
CIA and and and this is a stage of the
book and many people who watch this
might be like why are you hanging out
with CIA officials and of course he's
lying to you
Richard Lee's father was a senior CIA
official during the Cold War all right
but he he complained he was chasing
al-qaeda early on he worked in and then
ran Alec station which was trying to
find bin Laden before 9/11 but he felt
that when Bill Clinton ordered missile
strikes at a farmers
plant and Sudan that was there was you
know it the intelligence was unclear
according to blee and he felt that
Clinton launched that missile strike
because he was trying to divert
attention from the Monica Lewinsky
scandal and that was sort of the first
example you know in his career of
politics getting in the way of what he
thought should have been a more
aggressive response or a more direct
response in Afghanistan - okay - then
the Col balmy happens and there was
again that was right that was in the
September 2000 right before gore and
Bush have you know one of the closest
elections in US history and again
there's a lack of response he's a
hardliner he wants to hit back bin Laden
in Afghanistan aggressively and again
Clinton sort of doesn't really do
anything because it's just before the
election and and so this is again
politics and interfering and what he
felt was national security but so he
brings us up to you sixteen years later
yeah I mean he he was talking about it
more in terms of micromanagement and the
hyper politics of Washington um
Benghazi had happened this sense that of
be cautious if if anything goes wrong
it's gonna you know destroy the boss
sorry the career of the political leader
in Washington go so he's just said the
micromanagement and the caution was you
know preventing the CIA from operating
effectively and look you know bleah
you know you know wasn't well he wasn't
he he wouldn't say it in detail but he
was operating in Afghanistan and
Pakistan this is where the US was
carrying out drone strikes there's a lot
of people who would say he has no
credibility but he he stood by the drone
strikes he you know stood by there he
was haunted by 9/11 he tried to find bin
Laden and time the book describes this
didn't felt he'd failed the American
people and you know was was frustrating
with how politicized everything was
getting so okay so he's kind of this
beginning nugget the inspiration that
you get and then you go with the Senate
investigation committee right yeah
and so it's you know he claims that
there was you know bleed is telling me
in 2016 there's kind of a rules of the
road for how the CIA is supposed to
operate differently than during the Cold
War and so I the book starts in the 70s
there's this big Senate investigation
called the church committee Frank Church
a senator from Idaho ran it it was great
reporting by Seymour Hersh then of the
New York Times about all kinds of
everything from CIA assassinations
abroad you know to the CIA operating the
u.s. rumors of J Edgar Hoover
surveilling and harassing Martin Luther
King so this it's an amazing sort of
bipartisan investigation it's
correctly.i hokey the most interesting
stuff that came out of that like the
most startling to you
hi there were I'll strike you're for the
record everybody Elizabeth is a better
writer than I am and so she's trying to
pull out human stories no no it's true
actually I've got one but the the scale
of the abuses the FBI like open files
and carried out investigations on a half
a million Americans that were engaged in
legal and political activity you know it
was their constitutional right they
weren't doing anything criminal so they
were surveilling and harassing and
infiltrating groups on the right the
John Birch Society and then famously
Martin Luther King you know many people
know this they he he was on his way to
accept the Nobel Peace Prize and they
wrote a fake letter to him and sent him
a recording of what they said was you
know recording it would prove he was
having affairs on his wife and on the
letter which was this anonymous letter
but typed up by FBI officials you know
urged Martin Luther King to kill himself
before he would go accept the Nobel
Peace Prize and it was part of this
broad campaign to discredit him led by
Jagger Hoover because he believed he was
a communist you know they would
routinely break into the homes of people
and and wiretap them they would leave
incriminating information in homes they
would leave letters to design to sort of
break up people's marriages you know it
was rampant and and then what was
interesting in that one of the most
arresting characters to meet as I
started the book was one of the chief
investigators
the church committee was a guy named
fritz Schwartz
Princeton's middle initials were a oh so
his name is FAO words he's a blueblood a
young ski on if that's the right word
that family that owns the toy store in
New York and he'd gone to Harvard and so
he started debriefing as part of the
church committee all of these former CIA
and FBI officials and it was a select
committee and their goal was to see the
extent of wrongdoing by all these
agencies during the Cold War he thought
he would identify more and sort of get
along better with the CIA officials at
that point the CIA was dominated by said
Ivy League wasps like himself hmm he
found it you know blood-chilling to talk
to these CIA officials he watched bill
Colby a former CIA director just lie
through his teeth and he said Colby was
the best liar he'd ever seen that Fritz
the chief investigator for the committee
couldn't catch him in a lie he was cold
it was so good at it and then he came to
kind of like the FBI agents more they
were sort of he said they sort of went
to afford him and they were sort of
pejorative but sort of more
working-class he was really alarmed he
was more alarmed by what the FBI did
because they were undermining American
democracy
you know infiltrating Vietnam war
protest groups students for a Democratic
Society I'm spreading disinformation you
know getting on walkie-talkies and
trying to confuse demonstrators to
disrupt what they were doing you know
there was all these dirty tricks that
they were running to stop the anti-war
movement and so he was more angry at the
FBI he felt that was a deeper threat to
American democracy even though he liked
the FBI agents better and just the last
thing it was interesting talking at the
I agents cuz they all said they had to
do these things they had to break the
law to protect the country and Elizabeth
but although he says we've covered over
the years that did I think there's
certain people that break the law
because they like to break the law or
they just write the danger to me is how
people rationalize their actions
so all these FBI's
said I I did this to kind of prevent
communists from infiltrating America and
destroying you know our way of life and
my family and and they really believed
it and when you start rationalizing
illegal actions it doesn't stop and it
gets very dangerous so what were the
consequences of the expose of all of
these you know the revelations of all of
these illegal break-ins and and you know
twisting of facts and did anything come
out of it so yes I'm sorry for the
previous long answer I just do not give
a short answer please what you do this
is a little drier but it's extraordinary
going back and looking at it this whole
system there's some Watergate reforms
and responsible mixing and then the
church reforms so a very soon it's about
reining in the CIA and the FBI and
reining in out-of-control presidents so
new intelligence committees are created
in the house in the Senate as
investigation there's a new FISA Court
with the federal judges in it that are
supposed to approve all surveillance
inside the United States again the basic
idea there is that you are gonna have
all three branches overseeing the FBI
and CIA and completing judges and
members of Congress and the president to
control these groups also Jimmy Carter
comes in and he puts in law the
existence of independent councils like
Robert Mulder or Archibald Cox you know
it was fired during Watergate to
investigate wrongdoing by the executive
branch FBI directors are limited to ten
year terms so you don't have a Jagger
Hoover there for 40 years inspectors
general are created these are the there
was just an Inspector General created to
look at the trillions in spending in
coronavirus relief Trump fired that
inspector general but again these are
officials appointed by Congress to look
at what the executive branch is doing
last thing the CIA now has to produce
written they're called covert action
findings they describe a covert program
at the CIA is gonna carry out overseas
the president has to sign that written
finding I mean they're vague CIA can do
things but copies of those findings
after the president
are given to the leaders of both houses
in Congress and the leaders of I'm sorry
both parties in Congress and the also
the leaders of the intelligence
committees from both parties as well and
again this is where you had this
informal vague conversations where the
CIA would go do things now it's in
writing Ford and Carter embraced all
these reforms so it was these kind of
rules of the road for a guy like Richard
Lee who said there's a presidential
finding I can go do X Y & Z in this
country and I'm not gonna if a new
presidents elected you know I'm not
gonna be sort of put on trial by the new
American president you know who
disagrees with what the last American
president asked me to do and and so when
Trump says it's out of control and no
one knows what's going on there's this
massive system that was created in the
late 70s it's not perfect but it still
exists would not prosecute CIA agents
for carrying out Bush's orders all right
so what what changes after the church
reforms is that it isn't you know the
CIA doing so secretly without the
president knowing it's not you know J
Edgar Hoover sending out guys without
the president knowing the presidents by
the way during the Cold War knew about a
lot of bad stuff and condoned it this is
we get to 9/11 and it's George W Bush
deciding I'm gonna order the CIA to go
out and carry out rendition and torture
and do it in secret and I as president
have the power to do it to protect the
country and then more importantly that
FISA Court the federal judges that are
supposed to authorize all surveillance
Bush just ignores that he and Cheney
carry out now this you know famous
famous warrantless mass surveillance
where they just say I don't need the
approval in judicial branch I in terms
of national security can carry out mass
surveillance on my own that's broken by
Jim risin and Eric Lichtblau a New York
Times but so the system is already sort
of being weakened but the difference is
it's an out of control president not out
of control FBI and CIA in 2001 wait now
clapper was he hold on you it was
clapper more Pete what was he working on
what was he in clapper was he was well
it's really he
he's by he's there the head of the
Defense Intelligence Agency he's a
career person he's fascinating as his
father works for the NSA
he leaves and intelligence he believes
that you know the intelligent he speaks
truth to power and they inform policy
makers and you know we'll get into his
yeah well his testimony and the Snowden
thing but he's he's a character in the
book also of you know here meet somebody
who spends their career in the
intelligence area Joan Dempsey is a
woman who Rises through from a Navy sort
of officer and intelligence all the way
up to being the number three official at
the CIA but I mentioned her because both
Dempsey and clapper are involved with
Iraq WMD and this is just a pure
intelligence failure where and Dempsey
and clapper both said it that they were
so afraid they were the intelligence
community was so ashamed in a way I'm
and I'm not justifying what they did by
missing 9/11 that they overreacted to
the WMD argument in Iraq they said there
was pressure for they clearly Bush and
Cheney wanted the Intel just gonna just
say there was WMD in Iraq but both of
them said the intelligence community
happy to come to that finding based on
flimsy evidence because they didn't want
to miss you know a big threat to the
country have another 9/11 carried out on
their watch one critique of the book
I've gotten is that you know I'm too
easy on these intelligence officials in
the intelligence community in general
that they haven't performed well they
missed 9/11 they were wrong about Iraq
WMD and they you know continue to miss
things and I think that's a that's a
fair critique did you want to tell it
more from their point of view rather
than get into a critique of their
actions I did and I you know another and
this is all kind of this is the spinach
yeah one other you know one other thing
that comes out of the 70s is a Jimmy
Carter like we have the federal
government is full of professional civil
servants yeah like back to the 1800s
when basically every federal employee
was somebody
who got the job because they were
politically loyal to the presidents and
and there was part of the progressive
movement was to try to have civil
service exams and have people work for
governor in their careers and and have
you know there'd be less patronage so
the system evolves
there's the Hatch Act which bars you
know federal employees from engaging in
political activities that came about in
the 40s because Democrats were using
federal employees to help them win
elections and then Jimmy Carter does
another reform so there's something
called a senior executive service and
Joan Dempsey is in that but the point is
you know there's all kinds of
regulations barring career officials the
ones that Donnell Crump I'm sorry Donald
Trump is accusing of carrying out coos
where they're under all this oversight
by Congress and different parts of the
executive branch yet and look they're
not perfect they're bureaucrats and we
can talk about that more they they spin
they leak they want to you know boost
their own you know their own
organizations budgets and standing but
there's this huge system that's been
involved over the decades to try to you
know control them from you know plotting
cooze that Trump completely ignores so I
just decided to do a series of
characters in the book that you know
spent their careers or intelligence and
this one other one and we're all stuck
for that will hurt he's a member of
Congress in our Republican was a CIA
officer for a decade after 9/11 and he
you know becomes a character later
during the Trump era but it's
essentially a group of FBI and CIA
officials that I track starting in the
70s when this new system comes out to
kind of control them through the through
the Trump era what are the conflicts
that I found really interesting and also
the way that you will the two characters
together of course to the Attorney
General William bar and James clapper
and it seems like from their backgrounds
though bar is like this Upper West Side
New Yorker sort of the lead
well-educated copper comes from more of
an army or actually an arm right right
like obsessed with breaking codes and
you know that kind of stuff
and yet they both have a suspicion of
executive power of being being curbed in
any way and they don't both seem to have
a suspicion of congressional oversight
right in the way that you describe their
early years and yet by 2019 like they
both seem on the same track and in some
ways conservatively 2019 you have Barra
choosing clapper of being part of the
deep state
you know organizing the the
investigations of Trump how does that
happen it's Donald Trump he is such a
polarizing sort of figure that he sort
of you know the establishment kind of
the Washington style different sort of
splits in a way and the vast majority in
the south wind counted I think turns
against Trump a bar obviously joins the
the Trump camp but you're right about
clapper and again it's you know with the
protests that are going on now
clapper you know the NSA was kind of
performing surveillance on Americans I'm
like you know the Vietnam War groups and
I asked clapper about that and he
supported those activities in the 70s
saying like the cities were burning and
you know the government needs to sort of
maintain order so you're absolutely
right about how similar they are the
difference is that you know clapper
comes in the conclusion that you know
Trump is undermining all of the he does
and clappers a controversial figure but
yeah clapper claims that there are facts
and they got the facts wrong in Iraq he
gave this you know problematic Ron Wyden
and many others say false answer about
the extent of surveillance that Snowden
revealed later on but but clapper claims
that the job intelligence officials is
to give you know unfurnished unvarnished
facts to policymakers and to the
president so that they will make
decisions that will not risk the lives
of American soldiers needlessly or
endanger the country many people will
dismiss that but you know clapper
dismissed what they well they will so
it's this is a broader argument and we
face it like so the flipside of this is
that what I heard about Donald Trump's
mentality so
Piper claims basically there's objective
fact you can present a presidential
Daily Brief that kind of more or less
you know tells you what's happening and
do it in a relatively objective way like
I've kind of theoretically very straight
newspaper story and what I heard about
you know Trump is that he you know grows
up in this hyper-competitive world of
New York real estate and he just he
thinks that everybody is kind of putting
a little spin on the ball exaggerating
in fact you know trying to get advantage
somehow so he doesn't believe that the
you know the reporters sitting in front
of him in the White House press
conference you know are asking you know
straight facts I mean clearly
everybody's performing to a certain
extent and a press conference but he
just thinks that that government experts
like certain presidents more than others
that these career government officials
are like carrying out the orders of one
president faster than other he doesn't
sort of believe in the concept of
nonpartisan public service he thinks
people just don't hack that way right I
think an imperfect version of that
exists and I think you have to believe I
don't know it's easy to hold him up but
like dr. Tony Fauci like you need the
pandemic shows us you need some kind of
basic level of objective fact that the
public and policymakers can agree on so
you can respond to a pandemic and
otherwise you just get the kind of chaos
we see I think coming from trauma just
to go back to one minute so just do bar
and clapper and wrote like overlap and
have a relationship no they never meet
and then the big split here is that and
thank you again everybody else is doing
a great job so why does Barr end up with
Trump and this again goes back to the
trauma of the 70s so there all these
reforms are enacted to control like I
said out of control presidents and
there's a group of conservatives one of
them is Antonin Scalia who is a legal
scholar you know and then he's in the
Justice Department in the Ford
administration and then there's two
White House staffers Dick Cheney and
Donald Rumsfeld worked for Ford all
right and together they come up with
this belief that
the post-watergate reforms week in the
American presidency that the War Powers
Act for example which was again separate
but it was another example of Congress
saying to the president you can't make
war without the legislative branch's
approval
there were many conservative people who
felt that roe v wade and many of the
court decisions that move the head the
liberal agenda you know was again an
infringement on the kind of president's
power that the judges were gaining too
much power
so Barr agrees with this theory that the
executive branch the president were
weakened too much after Watergate
everybody argues this through the Reagan
era all right but Reagan and Bush and
even George W Bush all sort of by this
basic belief post Nixon that if you
don't respect Congress in the courts as
a president it's gonna hurt you
politically that you have to embrace the
sort of division three equal branches of
government but bill Barr his whole
career you know he's believed that the
presidency is the most important branch
in terms of saving the country he gave a
speech at the Federalist Society last
fall where he said if you look at
history and when there's the country's
threatened by war or the you know
economic depression or natural disaster
it's it's the presidency that axis
sizably and say to the country and he
argued that you know Trump's travel ban
being blocked by some federal judge on
the west coast was an example of the
president being unable to act in the way
he should and that all these
congressional investigations of Trump
were just harassment and improper and he
you know it's I've used the term
ideologue meets grifter like believed
that there should be a strong presidency
and then some folks describe the
president as a Krister depend it
underlies this that it depends on what
you believe saving the country is I mean
there's no earth you know darling
and and we might believe it's something
else so bill Barr
you know sat you know Trump talked about
dominating the streets and you know in
these White House meetings yeah and the
calls with governors and Bill Barr use
that exact same language he's been this
way throughout his career he bar was
also the Attorney General under George
HW Bush so when the Rodney King riots
happened Barr sent 3,000 federal
officers to Los Angeles and in an old
interview I found of him he he he said
you know there should have been federal
civil rights charges brought against the
officers who beat Rodney King and they
were acquitted and that caused the riots
but he said they should have brought
federal charges against all the riders
also he thought it was a chance after
the Rodney King riots to crack down on
all the gangs in Los Angeles so he this
whole thing where he's you know and now
and more recently with the the Floyd
protests right where Barr is calling an
international guard and sending out you
know there are prisons agents without
insignias to kind of you know bar
believes that the way you save the
country is through the law and order
clearly you know many Americans don't
but yeah yeah he's always been this way
and in the process now he's you know
what's amazing about right now is he's
enabling Donald Trump and of course
clapper would agree with them yes and
that this is this key kind of 2016 split
and I get to I mean a term I use in the
book and it's not very artful another
way that you could talk about the
permanent government or the
institutional government right Oh
clapper and I say institutional
government because I think look
everybody has political bias including
you know but when I say institutional
government it's the their biases towards
their institution so I think what happen
with clapper is that when when Trump
started attacking the intelligence
community I see 2016 Brangwyn and then
they and they saw and you know the
Russians had been doing disinformation
stuff in the US for decades well as they
saw the extent of disinformation that
was going on in 2016 Trump I'm sorry
clapper became genuinely concerned that
Trump was sort of tacitly you know
working with the Russians are possibly
colluding
with them right and so that combination
leads you know the fact that Trump is
attacking the intelligence community and
sort of defaming all these people that
clapper had worked with that clapper
turns on so in your reporting and in
talking with people who are the
so-called deep state in Trump's views
but I forget the turn but the people
that he's attacking how do they continue
how do they justify staying in their
jobs how do they how do they sort of
square like I disagree with everything
this guy is saying and doing but I'm
gonna try to keep doing this job even as
these destroying departments and
institutions and what do they say they
say I spent some time with like FBI
agents and they they're like you know
they say like they like to just go kick
in doors and like get bad guys and they
there's a disguise all we do that they
can still do that and there's kind of a
so another character in the book is a
guy named Tom O'Conner he was a cop from
Northampton Massachusetts in western
Massachusetts he joins the FBI just
before 9/11 he ends up investigating the
USS Cole bombing in Yemen travels the
world he's at the Pentagon after 9/11
recovering the bodies and victims there
he even goes to Iraq after the invasion
there and investigates the Blackwater
security guards shooting of people there
but if you fast-forward to 2018 he's the
head of like the FBI agents Association
it's sort of they're you know they're
Union they don't it's the closest thing
to have the Union they're not allowed to
legally and he's running this Union
though during the shutdown where we're
you know Pelosi and Trump have this
battle it's about funding for the border
wall and it's the longest shutdown in US
history and you know there's like fifty
thousand FBI employees across the
country they're not getting paid for
weeks at a time and there was you know
you know younger staffers coming in to
senior FBI officials in the 50 field
offices around the country and they're
they're in tears they can't feed their
families they're worried about missing a
credit card payment and they like lose
their security clearance in their
livelihood they ended up setting up
food pantries in FBI offices around the
country so that you know FBI employees
could help each other and it's you know
we're sitting here being sympathetic
towards the FBI the people that were
rogue in the in the 70s but what struck
me and spending time with them is that
they the FBI's divided like the country
like a lot of people love Donald Trump
in the FBI and a lot of people hate him
and what word me is it so a Connor
recently retired he in this amazing
career and he and what's the
investigative white you know supremacist
as well so from al-qaeda to white
supremacists you know I said his job was
like you know investigating evil in all
of its forms but I said him now you're
retired you know there's this deep
disgust for sort of the political class
among FBI cuz I like would you ever run
for office to try to make things better
and he was like no no David you know I'd
want to do something that had actual
meaning and so that level of disgust
with like our political process and
Congress and also frankly the media you
know is a bad sign and I worry that you
know maybe the FBI is too big but I
think you need a group of people that
are willing to work from this you know
the Center for Disease Control to you
know the EPA to the FBI you know with
the strong sir you know the strong
supervision of elected politicians again
the elected leadership I mean like how
do those people work when the president
is undermining their agency there there
is a culture of I'm a political like and
they kind of use I'm just gonna I'm
carrying out you know orders among the
kind of people out in field officer or
even like the federal prosecutors
they're out you know prosecuting people
around the country you know I think
Washington is different or New York
those are you know more political
offices they they feel they're public
servants they like you know you know
enforcing the law they like I don't know
enforcing environmental regulations they
like working on education policy so it
does just disturb them that the
president is sort of attacking them and
calling them you know the FBI agents who
investigated Trump Russia you know the
president calling them humans
scum but I worry that people just aren't
gonna want to engage in public service I
think an imperfect form of public
service can exist and we need it you
know and otherwise we won't sort of
function as a society or a democracy my
goodness well if you talk about the
pandemic you know we have the latest
polls show that most you know liberals
think that the the death tolls that the
guardians rating are actually higher
that the government is under estimating
them and then conservatives think that
the death tolls are lower than it's all
underestimated so it's might change that
with Texas Florida and Arizona
correct correct you know what you know
no I agree it's just that it it's
changing this week but you know it was
the pandemic is something I've talked
about where it's like you need to have
facts basic agreed upon facts problem
though of course is that because we're
so divided people don't believe in facts
a and until it hits you in the face and
you don't see it and you're not all
watching the same news and you're not
all getting your facts in the same place
the minute like so New York is seen as
like this liberal Dan of evil and of
course they're all gonna get the sick
you know and the numbers are exaggerated
or they deserve whatever now it's
hitting in the red states that weren't
believing it and you'll sure you're
gonna start to see a change and believe
in fact yes and it's inevitable and you
know part of its the explosion of the
web and I love the web and it's gonna
explode but I think that it's made it
the web has made it much easier for mass
amounts of disinformation to be spread
I'm jealous and frustrated you know that
Facebook and Google you know and Twitter
get to have you know when when you post
a magazine story or I post a magazine
story we can be sued if it's defendant
Victoria or false you know they don't
face those restrictions and you know I'm
not an expert on how you fix that but so
part of the problem is just any
conspiracy theory you want right left is
a half a dozen keystrokes away and
you know many politicians but
particularly President Trump you know
traffic and conspiracy theories yeah so
they they exacerbate the misinformation
which we're always gonna have but that's
what's you know critically destructive
about what Trump has done do you think
that that is why he has ignored or is
pretending that he didn't see the
briefings about the erection bounties
for you know killing paying the Taliban
to kill Americans I'm sure you saw like
today well yesterday he was like no I
wasn't briefed then it comes out well he
actually got it in February the briefing
and the intelligence unnamed
intelligence officials are saying it's
absurd and impossible that he didn't see
it it's absurd that anybody would wait
for it to be a hundred percent truthful
or factual remember because they were
saying well it wouldn't go to him I
think his press secretary said what
wouldn't go to him until it was
confirmed no it's had that tension
between them again well that they they
you know the president I know presidents
perfect and then give me my to be fair
to Trump thing like every modern
president I found has been suspicious of
like the bureaucracy and right Reagan
came in and thought the State Department
was thwarted his effort to confront
communism Obama thought Pentagon
generals were leaking
you know troop increases in Afghanistan
to box him in but no nobody has been so
dismissive of government advice so I
think he was told this but he just
ignored it or didn't absorb it you know
he doesn't read he doesn't read the
presidential Daily Brief
it's the same thing with the coronavirus
warnings he's he's always been
suspicious of experts when he ran the
Trump Organization and current White
House officials told me this that he you
know in the White House and when you
were in the Trump Organization he would
rely on outsiders to get advice about
real estate deals and now in the White
House he you know calls Sean Hannity and
and others and and relies on those you
know he's sort of do you think you might
have seen it and just didn't believe it
didn't want to believe it you know he
look he well who you know the great
mystery of trumpet
right Hammad or or is it just that you
know Donald Trump was dissed by the
establishment Michael Morell the deputy
CIA director who wrote an endorsement of
Hillary Trump during the campaign where
L told me he regretted running that
endorsement that an early mistake that
the intelligence community made was was
attacking him having former officials
endorse Clinton publicly alienated Trump
made him see the CIA as political and so
he you know you know I'm not look yeah I
should have acted on the intelligence
but though you know his he's already
suspicious and he turns on people very
quickly and so the point here is that
you know there's a lot of people that
are critical of Brennan and clapper in
their public attacks on Trump and they
say it doesn't really change any minds
and it just plays into the conspiracy
theory that the CIA is this highly
political organization that's attacking
Trump so I you know and you can even get
into journalism I die so oddly I'm kind
of arguing for some people that try to
be nonpartisan including journalists
reporters who are just on a beat that
are you know there's plenty of
commentators you know attacking Trump
but when you kind of take the beat the
debate and and I tried to be fair in
this book you play into that I do say
that the president's constantly
exaggerating and lying and believe the
Washington Post that he's you know
whatever it was 16,000 false and
misleading statements but I try to kind
of understand that you know what that
what are the sincere beliefs that lead
bill Barr to do what what are you doing
what are the way the sincere beliefs
lead bill Barda yeah he's doing in terms
of if that makes me sense it's like this
hyper political environment where yeah
you know it just scorched earth and
there are no facts and you know just
push back on on any kind of agreement
and I worry about where it's leading us
so here's just to put you in Trump's
head for a minute which is impossible
but if the deep State forget
if this if the intelligence community is
now using surveillance on the black
lives matter movement the police the
protest against police violence using
facial recognition you know collecting
as much intelligence on everyone out
into the streets as possible
it's troubling to see that as the deep
state or as the in his interest I argue
in the book and I've been there's been
mixed reviews but that he's creating a
deep state of his own right and I don't
know if it's like a you know out of fear
or some like plot he has to be an
authoritarian leader but he you know has
Rudy Giuliani as kind of his private you
know foreign policy apparatus he has
Sean Hannity as kind of a private
communications arm of the White House he
stonewalled efforts by Congress to find
out you know what what his policies are
on what he's doing and I I think that's
because of the leaks and and his fear of
everyone attacking him but the danger is
that you know he's creating this this
system that has sort of no transparency
no one is being you know overseen by
Congress or the courts and and this
rationale the rationalization that he
has to kind of tweet his policies out
there because no one will carry them out
you know they're very dangerous because
it's a concentration of power and in a
way where there's very little
transparency and that's how you get the
kind of rationales that lead to abuses
such as calling for like active duty
military and streets so I don't know if
he's doing this because he he wants to
be an authoritarian leader or he feels
that he's the victim of all these
bureaucrats that are undermining him and
he has to speak directly to the American
people and then you know the news media
is lying but it's a really dangerous
dynamic and I had current White House
officials tell me this you have I'm just
gonna say one more thing you have this
great quote where Frank Church is
interviewed on Meet the Press you know
and he says and he's warning about the
technological advances he says it could
be turned on this is what in 1972 it be
turned on the American people and used
to facilitate a system of government
violence no American would have any
privacy left such as the capability to
monitor everything telephone
conversations tell everyone doesn't
telegrams it doesn't matter
there would be no place to hide and then
he says at the end of the videos we must
see to it that this agency and all
agencies that possesses technology
operate within the law and under proper
supervision so that we never cross over
that abyss that is the abyss from which
there is no return aren't we kind of in
that abyss we are Manor yeah and so
Congress is gonna stop doing effective
oversight of the intelligence community
because it's become so partisan yeah I
know the committee the intelligence
committees aren't really working the
FISA Court which was supposed to oversee
surveillance the judges have sort of
become a rubber-stamp half of the
surveillance of Carter page the Trump
aide was improper you know there was it
was faulty evidence it should have
should have gone on for as long as went
on it you know there was not
surveillance of Trump Tower or as Trump
claims exaggerating but there's there's
abuse is happening and so the digital
age has given these agencies more power
than ever to spy on us every detail of
our lives and you know where we need
ironically one of the few and off in on
a positive note you know one of the
funniest and unique alliances in
Congress today is between Rand Paul the
Republican libertarian Kentucky and Ron
Wyden the Liberal Democrat from Oregon
and there is like wide agreement you
know from the left and the right about
our need to protect privacy but we're so
polarized that we haven't been able to
come up with like legislation and
reforms to kind of govern the digital
age the 70s there was a crisis there was
an investigation and reforms and a new
system emerged I'm convinced you know we
can do that again now and create a
better system that I think disperses
power
I want oversight by all three branches
of government I don't want a more
powerful president like Bill barda's and
I'm a journalist but I want more
transparency and some trucks refusal
they'll hand over anything doing
Pietschmann investigators you know
Richard Nixon
and it over things to impeach yes to you
yeah that was terrifying so this is a
dangerous moment for American democracy
but I do think there are kind of basic
principles people believe in and I think
that you know we can get through this
people should be my little lioness then
be skeptical of kind of objective fact
and skeptical of objective journalists
and skeptical of objective you know
government officials but don't be
cynical about them yeah I think there
are people trying to get across basic
facts and you know because we have to
reform and and govern the you know come
up with the rules for the government
sorry for the digital age and protect
our privacy and and counter all this
disinformation for political gain
anyway I'm convinced we can do it we've
done it before
and we have to do it because it is very
dangerous what's happening today okay
well I really hope you're right I'm
trying it's an election should vote for
who but everyone should vote and and
you're really not gonna say no I don't
think that's mine no I don't know it's
back to you know clapper and Brennan and
that that that argument yeah and it's
you know it's it's don't believe the
conspiracy theories whether it's you
know far left or far right conspiracy
theories is my thing and and yeah if
it's not in the like quote-unquote
mainstream media it's on the Wall Street
Journal and you're conservative that's
it's probably not true and if you're
liberal and you're seeing some crazy
thing about Trump and it's not in the
New York Times it's probably not true I
know that people are gonna scoff at that
but you know there's like I said libel
laws and other things that govern the
way most news organizations report and
all the vitriol and conspiracy theories
on all sides I think is just dangerous
and leading to distrust and more and
more division well thank you this book
is it's really great it's a really great
read to so actually it's a
a lot of characters a lot of juicy
details and a great rendering of history
seriously really girl coming from you as
a fantastic writer and journalist who
I've known for decades that means a
great deal so but anyway thank you for
doing this Lola
thanks David